hallo mein name ist luca und wir spielen
heute ein absolutes scheiß spiel das
spiel heute als peaches game ever und es
ist auch das sieht man glaube ich in
diesem spiel geht es darum dass man
tatsächlich war das kommt mir ganzen
vorzeitig x-ray minecraft ist so
aufgebaut wie minecraft es sind ein paar
minecraft texturen drin ich kann auch
hüpfen und springen und heidi teil und
ich bekomme gerade echt augenschmerzen
ich lauf gerade tatsächlich einen berg
hoch es sieht aber so aus als wäre ich
einfach immer noch ein extra gefahren
ich habe dieses spiel im internet
gefunden und dachte mir nur so was ist
denn das das ist doch nicht der
weihnachtsmann mütze oder ich verstehe
dass gerade gar nicht und ich was soll
überhaupt das da unten heißen act or
update states computer fehlt irgendwie
es auch noch eigenschaft von dem spiel
dass überall riesige schneeflocken
rumliegen
was macht ihr heute so ich spielt und
spielt riesige schneeflocke rumliegen
damit eine pixel gemeinschaft grafik und
da oben einfach mal so ein baum ist da
es einfacher fucking himmel
ich hab mir fallen die augen geschlagen
das ist doch nicht war ich also wenn man
wenn man jetzt rein theoretisch wenn man
so gucken würde wird man denkt okay das
ist minecraft mit ein paar licht fehlern
aber dann guckt man einfach so arm ist
dann schimpft jetzt mal abgesehen davon
dass sich übelste augenschmerzen gerade
habe findet ich an sich gar nicht so
schlimm dieses spiel zu spielen weil es
ist witzig wenn man so verpackte spiele
spielt ist es nicht alles klar ob ich
sehe gerade das da unten ein haus ist
das heißt gelaufen jetzt erst mache mama
a
treffer wir sind fc st
wir hätten das system diesen viele und
werden immer mehr
wenn du auf unserer seite stehst
schließlich uns an amazon länger bei
manthey und fasst seine fans angeht
dabei seien nutzt unsere maske und im
geschäfts- oder instagram und zu
beweisen dass wir würdig sein
hier hat
hallo hallo jetzt fragt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich was war das denn und
immer noch fragt ihr euch wieso spielt
du kannst das spiel das hängt alles
irgendwie zusammen das gerade war
nämlich ein gewinnspiel bzw eine
einblendung für die serie mit star rot
ob die bald auf amazon video leute schon
einige male auf twitter gesagt dass ich
solche art serien mark und ich habe auch
explizit ex-klub sie alles klar luca ich
habe wirklich explizit diese serie
erwähnen weil sie halt echt geiles oder
meinten die soja wir haben die wende
berlin fühlst du nicht rein theoretisch
mal so tun als wären ein kanal gehackt
wäre und ich dachte das ist eigentlich
ein ganz coole sache weil ihr könnte
auch etwas gewinnen ich hier eigentlich
mit so product placement immer recht
transparent möchte ich damit umgehen
jetzt gerade war hier allerdings keine
einblendung von unterstützung
produktplatzierung weil es keine ist es
ist einfach ein cooles gewinnspiel quasi
ich sehe dass hier eine treppe ist und
ich versuche jetzt mal das wieso kann
ich dann nicht wenn ihr euch jetzt also
fragt was was soll die story waldi habe
mich gefragt ob ich nicht zu diesem
event kommen möchte dass ich am 19
november in berlin und ihr könnt da halt
auch hinkommen wenn ihr an einem
gewinnspiel teilnehmen dann könnt ihr
mit mir zusammen da was machen oder mit
anderen usern ich glaube sarrazins auch
dabei ich will das jetzt gar nicht alles
sagen weil ich das spiel gern
weiterspielen möchte deswegen schaut in
die beschreibung in den ersten drei
zeilen habe ich diesen text reingepackt
und das rauchen link zu dem gewinnspiel
dabei und da können die teilnehmer müsst
euch eigentlich eine maske ausdrucken
und an bild damit kosten
ja wenn ihr da also bock drauf habt und
ihr denkler berlin hätte ich bock drauf
mit luca ohne serie koop-modus bergen
schneit dann guckt euch das an und daher
sind auch noch die anderen informationen
und wir spielen jetzt dieses meisterwerk
von spiel weiter ich bin immer bei so
product placement es war ein gewinnspiel
aber ich bin einmal vorsichtig bei weil
ich weiß dass ihr das eigentlich viel
mögen halt nicht so werbungen und was
alles aber ich finde es ist der coole
serie und da wollte ich einfach drauf
aufmerksam machen und ihr könnt auch
noch was gewinnen
ach lassen wir das aber schreibt mir
doch mal bitte in die kommentare was ihr
davon haltet ihr sagt jessica bei
solchen sachen ist echt nice ist ein
coole innovative ideen von den
unternehmen oder wenn ihr sagt nähe das
ist kacke dann mache ich den nächsten
nicht so viel davon als sicher dass
jetzt das von saturn und das habe ich
gemacht was beides echt coole sachen
waren schreibt mir eure meinung gerne in
die kommentare allgemein zu
produktplatzierungen das wird mich mega
wieso bin ich ja eigentlich wo bin ich
dass ich bin gefangen in dem nach
häusern ihrig versuch so werbung sachen
ich sag immer werbung aber es war
eigentlich ein gewinnspiel also
eigentlich könnt ihr euch freuen weil
ich euch was gäbe for free also okay ich
versuche halt gerade solche videos dann
immer unglaublich gut zu schneiden und
gibt mir aber immer extra das hat man
euch beim saturn blog gemerkt ich bin
übrigens wieder aus dem labyrinth heraus
gekommen und habe ich das jetzt auch
versucht mit dieser kleinen
zwischensequenz die dann noch mal so ein
zupacken wenn ich wirklich gehackt
worden wäre und je mit diesem glitches
game dass es wirklich dazu passt und
total verhext verpackt von glitches was
ist das denn jetzt spiele ich denn hier
überhaupt hoffe das was euch gefällt und
dass sie mir dann nicht als böse seid
wenn ich da ich halt einfach mal maul
wir haben hier vorne tatsächlich noch
ein riesiges schiff übrigens kann ich
halt tatsächlich nichts drücken
auslaufen
ich kann nicht schneller laufen ich kann
ein bisschen springen aber das ist auch
einfach behindert und mit linksklick
rechtsklick da passiert auch nicht
freunde hier vorne ist ein schiff ich
versuche mal ich bin auf dem schiff
drauf ich kann hier nichts machen kann
ich hier vielleicht irgendwie so jetzt
gewesen hier irgendwie das schiff an
und was wenn ich rein theoretisch mal
es ist abgestürzt damit würde ich dann
wohl sagen dass
ja es geht wirklich nichts mehr werden
euch das video gefallen hat würde ich
mich über eine bewertungen freuen
schreibt mir die kommentare was ihr
davon haltet eventuell falls ihr das
video ganz ganz spät erst 2016 jetzt
oder sohn die serie schon draußen
was haltet ihr von der serie ich würde
mich da echt freuen wenn ihr mir mal
eure meinung zu diesen ganzen placement
werbung sache von mir aus auch
ausführlich in die kommentare schreiben
und sehen wir uns bald wieder an link zu
der sache ist in der beschreibung lassen